at the entrance to the park where she
died the flowers left in memory of
Brianna Jai it was down along the Old
Railway line that a 16 year old life was
cut short a life that like so many
played out on social media in Tick-Tock
videos like this
and a life that's been honored by her
family Brianna was a much-loved daughter
granddaughter and baby sister they said
she was a larger than life character who
would leave a lasting impression on all
that met her Briana was beautiful witty
and hilarious Brianna was strong
fearless and one of a kind the loss of
her young life has left a massive hole
in our family
her friends and teachers they said would
feel the same and at Brianna's school
her head teachers said they would do
their utmost for pupils of what she
called a difficult and distressing time
Damien Harry's daughters knew Brianna
from school he said they were all
shattered piano is just
um a sort of beautiful what you know
um beautiful young girl
um quite active on social media
um similar to my daughters they're both
very stressed and
disbelief
um
being sick needing to take painkillers
for stress
so
um it's quite emotional for everybody
a 15 year old boy and girl remain in
custody Brianna was transgender police
say they have no evidence to suggest her
death was hate related police continue
to search inside the park where Brianna
was found they say they're pursuing
several lines of inquiry they've
appealed to anyone who was here on
Saturday to contact them anyone with
CCTV or dash cam footage from this area
at that time to share it with them
they've brought in more officers and
stepped up patrols to reassure people in
this Village a place shocked over the
loss of a young life in the heart of
their Community Greg Milam Sky News
cultureth in Cheshire